[Musique]
parlons un peu de ton père c'est
pourquoi il est interdit de sortir de la
forêt est ce qu'il t'a dit on va
demander à l'est nous sommes tous très
inquiet pour le musée
tout va bien maintenant elle simule
sortez de là tout de suite richard
tu m'as entraîne pour que je devienne
une machine et tu veux qu'il reste là
pourquoi il faudra qu'on a trop fait
fort kent outreau
[Musique]
si quelqu'un pose des questions on n'a
jamais vu cette santé en danger avec
elle parce que les gens veulent me faire
du mal et n'y a que mon père qui peut me
juger
tout ce que je veux c'est que tu me
fasses confiance
[Musique]
je peux faire confiance à personne
je voulais offrir une vie normale
pourtant je suis pas quelqu'un de normal
se tuer
[Musique]
c'est très dur
emmenez là
à
[Musique]
d'où est ce que tu viens en fait
pourquoi on trouve bizarre c'est ça non
je trouve magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est leur lève toi forme ap
oihana vous savez qu'elle est dangereuse
[Musique]
moi non plus je veux pas de perdre quand
et moi vous n'avez aucune idée de ceux à
qui vous avez affaire
plus de secrets pour quoi pourquoi ils
me veulent moi
[Musique]
je le sentais vraiment terrorisés
comme un renard coincés au fond de son
terrier
[Musique]
qu'est ce
là